[Music]
how are you friends, hector mejía greets you
with his brief information for today,
Wednesday, there will be different
vaccination clinics in schools
throughout the week,
they will give the first doses of the
facer vaccines from 3:30 to 5:30 in the afternoon
for older people  ages 12 and up
after three weeks these same clinics
will be offering second doses
you can walk in but it is
recommended that you make one on the
health district page check the
full list on disney.com for more details
changing topics
clark county commissioners  They will be organizing a
finance workshop for tonight. It will be
at the federal building from 6 to 7 at
night. It is totally free in order
to help the community understand
about budgets, investments,
planning, bankruptcy, debts and
credit records. You can also watch this
workshop at  through facebook or
youtube
and entertainment news from the
production team at saniag anun  ity
that will bring another festival to las vegas'
it's all about the greens get to
downtown las vegas and expire september 4 and 5
tickets will be on sale
starting friday
now at a glance at what awaits us in
terms of temperatures we will have
hottest day 106 degrees for today
wednesday this friday will be the hottest day
of the week with 108 degrees
this is higher than normal for the
start of june so stay
out of the sun if you can and have water on
hand have  a nice day too i am
héctor mejía and this was his brief
informative xc in spanish
[Music]